>>> DEVELOPING THIS MORNING, 16
AMERICAN MISSIONARIES, ONE
CANADIAN MISSIONARY ARE MISSING
IN HAITI AFTER BEING KIDNAPPED
BY ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
GANGS ON THE ISLAND, A GANG
WHICH HAS ALREADY KIDNAPPED
DOZENS OF PEOPLE THIS YEAR,
ABDUCTED THE MISSIONARIES OVER
THE WEEKEND AFTER THEY WERE
VISITING AN ORPHANAGE NEAR
PORT-au-PRINCE.
KYLIE ATWOOD HAS MORE FOR US
THIS MORNING.
WHAT MORE ARE YOU LEARNING ABOUT
THIS KIDNAPPING?
>> Reporter: LISTEN, KATE, THE
STATE DEPARTMENT HAS CONFIRMED
THAT THERE WERE 16 AMERICANS WHO
WERE KIDNAPPED IN HAITI OVER THE
WEEKEND BY A GANG THERE.
WE ARE TOLD BY THIS
ORGANIZATION, THIS NONPROFIT
CHRISTIAN ORGANIZATION BASED IN
OHIO THAT IN TOTAL THERE WERE 17
PEOPLE KIDNAPPED, 16 OF THEM
AMERICANS, FIVE OF THOSE WERE
CHILDREN.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT OF
COURSE WE ARE WATCHING EXTREMELY
CLOSELY.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS THAT
THEY ARE IN REGULAR CONTACT WITH
HAITIAN AUTHORITIES OVER THIS.
AND I WAS TOLD LAST NIGHT BY A
SENIOR ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL
THAT THE UNITED STATES STILL
DOESN'T KNOW WHERE EXACTLY THESE
AMERICANS ARE RIGHT NOW.
THEY WERE TAKEN HOSTAGE WHEN
THEY WERE LEAVING AN ORPHANAGE
WHERE THEY WERE DOING WORK IN
HAITI.
OF COURSE IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT HOSTAGE PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN
ONGOING IN HAITI FOR THE LAST
YEAR.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TRAVEL ADVISORY
TELLS AMERICANS DO NOT TRAVEL TO
HAITI.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THIS HAS
BEEN AN INCREASING PROBLEM IN
RECENT MONTHS.
THERE IS AN ORGANIZATION IN
HAITI THAT DID SOME RESEARCH
SHOWING THAT THERE WAS A 300%
INCREASE IN HOSTAGES TAKEN JUST
SINCE JULY OF THIS YEAR.
KATE?
>> KYLIE, THANK YOU FOR THAT
UPDATE.
LET ME BRING IN THE FORMER PRIME
MINISTER OF HAITI FOR MORE ON
THIS.
MR. PRIME MINISTER, THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW OF THIS GANG?
>> WELL, IT'S BEEN OPERATING FOR
SEVERAL YEARS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S A VERY DANGEROUS
GANG.
AND THEY'VE HAD SEVERAL
KIDNAPPINGS BEFORE.
IT'S A COMPLICATED AND DIFFICULT
SITUATION TODAY.
>> AS KYLIE SAID, KIDNAPPINGS
AND HOSTAGE TAKING IN HAITI
SEEMS OUT OF CONTROL AT THE
MOMENT EVEN BEFORE THIS WEEKEND.
WOULD YOU SAY THAT'S THE CASE,
IT'S OUT OF CONTROL, AND WHY?
>> THE SPIRAL OF VIOLENCE HAS
BEEN UNPRECEDENTED.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN HAITI, IT'S
A COMPOUNDING EFFECT OF THE
UNITED NATIONS HAD A MILITARY
COMPONENT, A MILITARY FORCE FOR
OVER 14 YEARS, SPENT OVER $14
BILLION, AND LEFT IN 2019,
CREATING A NEW SECURITY VOID.
THEY TRAINED THE POLICE AND THE
POLICE IS 16,000 POLICE OFFICERS
AND IS NOT REALLY EQUIPPED TO
FIGHT OFF THE TYPE OF GANG
ACTIVITY, THE TYPE OF GANG
WARFARE THAT'S GOING ON RIGHT
NOW IN HAITI.
SO THERE IS A VOID FOR A
MILITARY PRESENCE IN HAITI,
WHICH IS NOT THE CASE TODAY.
IT'S FAVORING THE GANGS AND IT'S
FAVORING VIOLENCE.
>> SO, I MEAN, YOU'RE KIND OF
GETTING AT IT.
WHAT IS NEEDED TO GET THIS UNDER
CONTROL?
I MEAN, BRING SOME SAFETY AND
SOME SECURITY TO A NATION THAT
IS STRUGGLING WITH SO MUCH FROM
NATURAL DISASTERS TO THE
ASSASSINATION OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> FOR SURE.
THE ASSASSINATION OF THE
PRESIDENT LEFT A LEGITIMACY
ISSUE, SO THERE IS A POLITICAL
PROBLEM TO BE SOLVED THROUGH
ELECTIONS.
THERE HAS TO BE A LEGITIMATE
GOVERNMENT TO DEAL WITH GANG
WARFARE AND ISSUES THROUGH
LEGITIMACY.
THERE IS DEFINITELY ON THE SHORT
TERM ASSISTANCE NEEDED TO THE
POLICE WITH EQUIPMENT, SUPPLIES,
EVEN MANPOWER TO FIGHT OFF THE
GANGS ON THE SHORT TERM.
BUT ON THE LONG RUN, HAITI NEEDS
TO RE-ESTABLISH ITS MILITARY.
SO THE MILITARY, THE POLICE
HAVING A STRONG FORCE, FIGHTING
TOGETHER AGAINST THESE GANGS AND
ALSO STOP THE DEPORTATIONS OF
CRIMINALS FOR A CERTAIN PERIOD
OF TIME, BECAUSE HAITI IS
RECEIVING OVER 100 CRIMINALS
FROM -- THAT ARE BEING DEPORTED
FROM THE U.S. BACK TO HAITI, AND
THE COUNTRY SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD
TO RECEIVE ANY MORE OF THEM.
IT'S CREATING -- YOU KNOW, IT'S
REINFORCING THE GANGS AND IT'S
CREATING A VERY, VERY FRAGILE
SECURITY SITUATION MAKING IT
EVEN WORSE.
>> I WAS ACTUALLY GOING TO ASK
YOU, BECAUSE IF YOU WERE IN YOUR
OLD POSITION, YOU WOULD BE
SPEAKING WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
AND WHAT WOULD YOU ASK OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN RIGHT NOW?
YOU DO THINK THERE IS A DIRECT
LINK BETWEEN THOSE BEING
DEPORTED FROM THE UNITED STATES
AS WE SAW THOSE DRAMATIC
PICTURES AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER
BACK TO HAITI, DO YOU THINK
THERE IS A CONNECTION TO THESE
GANGS?
>> OH, NO, IT'S NOT THE
MIGRANTS.
IT'S MOSTLY THE CRIMINALS, THE
HARDENED CRIMINALS THAT ARE SENT
BACK AFTER BEING IN JAIL.
IT'S FULL OF CRIMINALS GOING
BACK TO HAITI ON TOP OF THE
MIGRANTS.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IS THE
GANGS ARE MAKING THE COUNTRY
UNLIVABLE.
WHEN THE COUNTRY IS UNLIVABLE,
WE SEE THE IMMEDIATE EFFECT,
PROFESSIONALS ARE LEAVING HAITI
IN VERY HIGH NUMBERS, THE BRAIN
DRAIN IS GETTING EVEN WORSE.
SO WHAT I WOULD ASK PRESIDENT
BIDEN, IF I WAS IN OFFICE, I
WOULD ASK HIM, ONE, REINFORCE,
YOU KNOW, SENTENCING DOWN THERE,
REINFORCE THE HAITI NATIONAL
POLICE WITH SUPPLIES AND
EQUIPMENT, THAT WOULD BOOST
MORALE, AND ADJUST YOUR POLICY
UNDER THE HAITIAN MILITARY.
I KNOW THE HAITIAN MILITARY HAS
NOT BEEN A MODEL MILITARY IN THE
PAST, BUT TODAY'S SITUATION ON
THE GROUND CALLS FOR A MILIT